hoy vengo a hablarles de comida de
comida sin comida y el humano de menos
minutos para explicar
primeramente les pido que se imaginen el
siguiente escenario vamos paseando por
los pasillos del supermercado eligiendo
los productos de acuerdo a nuestra
necesidad estilo de vida e incluso algún
capricho vamos al departamento de frutas
y verduras agarramos un manojo de
espárragos luego nos pasamos al
mostrador de carnicería y nos pedimos un
par de kilos de bistec de res
tal vez cerdo o carnero nos movemos a
los refrigeradores y cogemos un paquete
mantequilla y que es algún tipo ahora
vienen hacia abajo y observa en su
carrito con todas sus compras qué
conveniente resulta todo este proceso
para adquirir nuestros alimentos no
siempre ha sido así que detrás de todo
esto para que podamos alimentarnos de
una forma tan cómoda los productos a los
que anteriormente el udi fueron
mencionados este año por la cnn como
algunos de los más dañinos en términos
de su impacto en la crisis ambiental
antes de continuar es importante
recalcar que dicho estilo de vida es
privilegiado y hay millones de personas
alrededor del mundo que para quienes la
alimentación representa algo mucho más
problemático o en su defecto inexistente
es por esto que en la lucha contra la
crisis ambiental debemos reflexionar
acerca de nuestra comunidad y como ella
contribuye a esta crisis
ahora sigamos uno de los posibles
caminos que tuvo que recorrer uno de los
productos que mencionamos para que
llegue a nuestras manos en un
supermercado carne de res
bueno pues lo más probable es que
tendríamos que iniciar en una granja
industrial nuestras vacas necesitan
reproducirse y en la mayoría de los
casos habrá que llevar la cría a la
adultez dejando de lado las condiciones
desafortunadas en las que algunos de
estos animales deben crecer habrá que
alimentarnos con pastura maíz o sorgo
junto con una gran cantidad de
antibióticos aunque eso es tema de otra
charla y abundante agua una vez adultos
se deberán sacrificar su carne
clasificar y cortar finalmente la carne
se empaqueta y se transporta para ser
distribuida cada uno de estos pasos
involucra en mayor o en menor grado una
pérdida que contribuye a la crisis
ambiental durante su crecimiento los
individuos vacunos emitirán grandes
cantidades de metal gratis en las
bacterias en su rom en su alimentación
requiere de cosechar los cultivos
anteriormente para lo cual se necesita
un tanto más de agua fertilizantes
plaguicidas y puso de equipo a base de
combustibles posibles
el procesamiento involucra un tanto más
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y producción de desechos industriales
para concluir
su transportación y distribución
involucra también la utilización de
medios de transporte generadores de
dióxido de carbono y la producción de
aún más de 6000 está claro también que
para hacer espacio para estas granjas
industriales que es probable que se
hayan tenido que deforestar grandes
porciones de bosques y selvas en
especial si se trata de países cálidos y
cercanos al ecuador ellos diezma
nuestros ecosistemas y disminuye la
capacidad natural de capturar carbón
poco sostenible no lo creen
ahora bien
nuestra historia humana y la de la
comida que consumimos es una que se
remonta a nuestros ancestros humanos más
antiguos con el homo habilis o el homo
erectus creo que todos estamos
conscientes de la importancia que tiene
la comida en nuestro desarrollo
individual pero no sólo esto sino que
también juega un papel clave en nuestra
historia blood evolutiva y es más es
posible aseverar que la razón por la que
somos humanos es por la forma en la que
comemos y es que la doctora herculano o
usted lo explicaba en sus sets aquí en
2013 nuestros cerebros humanos son más
grandes que los de otros primates porque
nosotros somos los únicos que cocinan al
final del día como los aficionados de
manga bien saben cocinar no es otra cosa
más que utilizar fuego para pre digerir
nuestros alimentos lo que nos permite
consumir muchas más calorías para
mantener un costoso cerebro empezamos
consumiendo alimentos crudos
recolectando los de la vegetación
aprendimos a cultivar los la agricultura
surgió asimilamos la cocina y el resto
es historia
el increíble crecimiento de población y
el desarrollo de la civilización humana
nos regreso al punto de partida los
pasillos de nuestro supermercado de
confianza
lo peor del caso es que las
consecuencias ambientales de los
sistemas industriales de producción de
alimentos que mencioné anteriormente con
el ejemplo la carne de res son tan solo
una pequeña fracción de la variedad de
consecuencias que tiene la industria en
su totalidad pensemos ahora en la pesca
la recolección masiva de los recursos
pescaderos nos ha llevado a agotar sus
poblaciones dramáticamente en canadá
desde 1990 ya se experimentaba un
colapso de las poblaciones de bacalao en
su costa este ninguna población vive
sola pues todos somos parte de complejas
redes ecológicas por lo que la
afectación al mundo natural no se queda
en el bacalao y es más más seguido que
no tampoco realizamos una pesca
inteligente con el objetivo de pescar lo
más que podamos en el menor tiempo
posible es común que las destructivas
redes que ocupamos atrapen igual a otras
especies que no eran el blanco en un
estudio realizado realizado en 2018 en
la universidad nacional autónoma de
méxico se encontró carne de delfín en
tres de 15 latas estudiadas de atún
y el poder destructivo de las redes
pesqueras no se queda ahí para maximizar
la producción es posible que se ocupen
redes profundas que llegan a tener
contacto con los suelos marinos lo que
puede dañar aún más a los ya en peligros
corales y algas
por otro lado igualmente en miras de la
practicidad el ejercicio agrícola
predominante es en los monocultivos eso
significa que se siembran amplios
planteos de una misma cosecha por
ejemplo maíz el tema es que los
ecosistemas no evolucionaron para
funcionar en dichas condiciones al tener
a cientos de individuos de la misma
especie uno al lado del otro compiten
vorazmente por los mismos recursos lo
que ocasiona un gráfico muy gran estrés
entre ellos y un agotamiento de los
nutrientes en el suelo tener individuos
de la misma especie todos juntos también
conlleva el riesgo de la propagación
fatal de patógenos sólo hace falta ver
la actual pandemia de kobe 19 y de
plagas también es por esto que se
requieren enormes cantidades de
fertilizantes y plaguicidas y así se
conecta el siguiente problema y otro
fijación la autorización se refiere al
transporte de fertilizantes por medio de
la acción de las lluvias en los suelos
de los cuerpos de agua como el golfo de
méxico desde finales de la primavera a
principios de otoño las costas se llenan
de cadáveres de animales marinos
los nutrientes que se les lavan en el
golfo desencadenan en un crecimiento
acelerado de la población de algas en la
superficie ellas ocupan toda la luz
proveniente del sol y no permiten que
las especies vegetales del fondo lleven
a cabo fotosíntesis por lo que mueren
así como el resto de fauna dependiente
de ellas
asimismo el uso de plaguicidas para
detener a una variedad de plagas tiene
un efecto alterno estas sustancias en
ocasiones no son lo suficientemente
específicas y terminan dañando a otras
especies en el caso de los insecticidas
si analizamos a los no únicos y nueves
numerosas investigaciones han comprobado
que tienen un efecto sub letal en las
abejas
es decir interfiere en este sistema
nervioso y afectan su comportamiento de
forrajeo y de ubicación en parte ello ha
ocasionado del conocido desorden de
colapso de las colonias razón por la
cual durante la década de 2010 se vio
una afectación grave a las poblaciones
apícolas e incrementarán los costos del
año
las consecuencias anteriormente
mencionadas no son una lista comprensiva
sino que una terrible lista con ejemplos
seleccionados de la diversidad de
efectos con los que la industria
alimenticia está contribuyendo a la
crisis hábilmente a la crisis ambiental
perdón
qué es lo que podemos hacer nosotros
como consumidores que se encuentra en
una situación privilegiada tenemos el
poder de elegir lo que comemos y la
oportunidad de aventurarnos a otras
opciones aquí íntegros cinco pasos para
convertirnos en consumidores más
responsables
1 debemos asegurarnos de aprovechar la
comida que adquirimos y que no la vamos
a desperdiciar seamos más analíticos
respecto a las cantidades que consumimos
y creativos
respecto a cómo podemos reciclar las
sobras la abundancia de desechos
orgánicos al campo abierto contribuye a
las emisiones de gases de efecto de
gases de efecto invernadero
de igual forma dietas ricas en fibra nos
hacen sentir más llenos durante más
tiempo por lo que pueden contribuir a
que no consumamos más de lo que
necesitamos
2 elijamos las opciones y contengan las
menores cantidades de plástico posibles
y en general de empaques no es extraño
ver cajas de té envueltas con la
película delgada de plástico que dentro
ocupan plástico para guardar bolsitas
que tienen etiquetas hechas de plástico
tal vez era buena idea regresar a la
tradición de comprar algunos productos
en el mercado local donde se puede
consumir a granel
podemos consumir menos carne en especial
la carne de res en parte una cultura
promovida por la industria de fast food
nos ha llevado a pensar que no se puede
tener un plato fuerte si éste no
contiene carne intentemos disminuir
nuestro consumo a una vez al día
o incluso un día a la semana buscando
complementar con opciones de otros
grupos alimenticios como vegetales
hongos leguminosas e insectos en
realidad las leguminosas nueces semillas
e insectos son una fuente de proteína no
animal extraordinario
4 disminuyamos nuestro consumo de
productos lácteos o en su defecto
proveemos alternativas en cuanto a
alternativas basadas en plantas la leche
de soya y la de avena son nuestra mejor
opción si queremos minimizar nuestra
huella ambiental y por último 5
consumamos local como explicaba
anteriormente la transportación y
distribución de productos generan
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y implican la producción de grandes
cantidades de basura el impacto se
vuelve aún mayor si se habla de
productos que viajaron grandes
distancias por lo que productos
importados pueden resultar
particularmente dañinas
puede parecer que el siglo 21 es uno
lleno de retos titánicos y problemas
enormes pero también es un siglo de
soluciones inteligentes y de cambios de
pensamiento respecto a nuestro estilo de
vida
tenemos la elección de cambiar pues es
mejor tarde que nunca la filosofía que
debemos adoptar es una reflexiva y
crítica de las implicaciones ambientales
que conllevan nuestras decisiones para
solucionar un problema de tal magnitud
se requiere de la acción continua en
todos los niveles de la sociedad
entonces por qué no empezar por nosotros
mismos muchas gracias